[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to google i o 2021 ask me
anything this is all about
ai in the cloud uh in today's session
we're going to hear
questions from all of you and i'm joined
by some special guests here in our
developer relations team
my name is carl weinmeister i am a
developer advocate
here at google my area of specialties in
ml ops which is basically the
application of devops and machine
learning
uh and i'm also joined by the new
carl yeah thank you i'm really excited
to be here
so my name is anushari vasava also we're
all colleagues
developer advocates for google cloud ai
my focus
is actually on pre-trained um apis that
we have that you can use to integrate
into your app or service
in addition to being really excited
about everything being in one home with
vertex ai
i also work on document ai which is ai
for all of your um business forms
zach do you want to go next thanks
uh i'm zach i'm also a developer
advocate uh i
happen to be based in london and i
specialize in
apis automl's and my kind of like sub
speciality is in everything to do with
vision and video applications
and i'm really excited to be here
awesome so let's go and kind of get
started i think you see that we have a
real nice mix of folks from different
backgrounds today
uh and we're also good friends so it'll
be a great session so
um let's start with the first question
about vertex
ai uh some of you may have seen some of
the press release of course in our
keynote
and are wondering what is vertex ai and
why is the release of it important uh so
anew what are your thoughts on that you
know
the reason why i'm really excited about
every being unified in one home
is that for me sometimes the hardest
part about
learning a new technology is getting
started you know especially
if you're trying to build an n10 system
you know you need to enable apis you
need a set of authentication you need to
maybe train data in different places and
bring it all together but now it's a
one-stop shop for
the whole life cycle that you might have
with your ai application
it's fantastic uh zach anything else you
want to add
um yeah i agree with with the new and
uh my sort of background experience
using
uh using vertex has been really positive
especially because i used to train like
quite a lot of auto ml models
that was like my go-to thing for
building demos and
one thing i really like about the new ui
is that it centralizes your
raw data in one place and then after
that you can create like different
annotation files so for me
building image models i can have one
uh raw source of the images and then
have one annotation that does image
classification and one
annotation that does uh like auto
detection and it structures these in
like a really intuitive way so
for me building vision based uh
automobile models it's a really nice
new sort of unified ui for the um the
structure of annotations to
the raw data yeah that's a great point
uh what's
you know what i think is really awesome
about vertex is that it sort of
brings together a lot of ai technologies
into one place like zach mentioned
uh this idea of bri creating what are
called managed data sets so it's the
same data
that you can use if you're going to
create different types of vision models
let's say
for classification object detection
whatever you're doing
um but also if you're building a custom
model say you're using tensorflow
and writing uh you know model yourself
with code
you have that traceability back to that
same data set
and the vertex brings all these
different services
together so it's like you load your data
you build a model
then the next thing is uh deploying that
model to an endpoint
it's all kind of walks you through a
flow so it's really intuitive and that
brings it all together
and uh allows you at different you know
types of roles whether you're a
developer data scientist to kind of
be able to use the tool easily so uh
so that's vertex um
let's go ahead and move on to our next
question here
um it is about uh ai
solutions uh so um
you know we talked about how vertex
brings a lot of uh
different services together another way
to think about things is different
levels of abstraction right so
if you're building an ai solution the
question is
what are those different levels of
abstraction so and i can start with this
one
um so we talked about custom models
right that's that ability that you
typically think of with data science
where you might visualize your data uh
you know write some code to train the
data uh build a model
take that uh file deploy it to an
endpoint and then predict with it right
so that's that sort of process
now automl has come along and allowed
you to create custom models with your
unique data to solve unique problems
um but without having to figure out the
best model for it
so that's another sort of level of
abstraction it kind of takes
some of those steps of the process and
does it for you and then
you also have apis that allow you to not
even bring your own data
simply leverage what google has on the
cloud like uh let's provide an image
and get some insights out of it you know
what what are the what's in that image
or what are some of the
uh let's put some bounding boxes around
some of the things that we find in that
image
these are all things that we've trained
against a large general data set so we
can apply it to all kinds of problems
finally one of the exciting things that
you know a new mention that she
focuses on is ai solutions and here's
where we're building business-oriented
solutions for things like
uh managing documents you know parsing
forms all those kind of things
we've taken the ai uh sort of uh brain
behind it
and made it very easy to use so you can
work at all these different levels
so i was kind of an intro to it um zach
anything
else you want to add about the different
ways you can work with
uh google cloud ai uh well yeah you
pretty much covered it all in terms of
like
when i'm building stuff i sort of come
at it from like a
a developer standpoint so i look at
what's the simplest and quickest way for
me to solve a problem so naturally i'll
go to the apis first okay if i can solve
a problem using the apis
that's perfect i can i can finish there
but then if the apis don't quite do
exactly what i want i build
a custom model with automl and then if
automobiles patterns don't match what
i'm doing
i do a custom model with a custom
training routines and things like that
so yeah
pretty much the exact same thing you
said
yeah it's great that you know maybe
you're a developer who just wants to
solve a problem how do i
you know get from a to b so that's where
those
apis might come in but also you know if
you go all the way down that's the path
you know the developers i work with
normally go through but if you are
building uh your own custom model you
have a lot of different options
right in vertex right tensorflow high
torch and you know you can really kind
of do anything that you need to
in one of the notebooks so yeah there's
a lot in there
great great um so you know we have some
folks that are looking at vertex
um for the first time and then we have
some folks that
may have some existing models um some
that are new to google cloud so they'll
use it for a while so
um our next question is about getting
started with vertex ai
um so let's start with the new just you
know what are your thoughts on how to
um get started from wherever your
starting point might be
yeah and so one of our colleagues sarah
she's published um
a number of code labs that will uh not
only like illustrate
what you're what you can do it'll give
you step-by-step instructions whether
you want to train a model uh using
tensorflow uh
we actually have some tech demos that on
the demos website
at i o that will show you you know high
level
um what you can do but then these code
labs give you step-by-step instructions
on setting up for yourself
also gcp credit if you might not already
be a gcp user to
test all these things out so i
definitely suggest starting there
you're fantastic um and uh you know zach
one of my favorite
tutorials is the one that you've built
with dale on our team around you know
analyzing your tennis serve you know
it's like it's a lab that i've run
through several times
what are your thoughts on just how to
get started get you know practicing
using ai
on google cloud review intelligence api
and that's the
same api we used in that demo to do that
pose recognition and
sort of the great thing about that is
like if you're just getting started and
if you if you look into ml courses it
would be quite intimidating but then
if you look into using like these apis
it's it's a pre-trained model so
especially things like the video
intelligence api it's my favorite one
because it has so many rich features in
there and what's really cool about these
features is
you just feed it a video and it will
tell you some really incredible things
like
there's any people in it if they're
posing in a specific way
or there's text in the video so if
you're just getting started it's a
really
sort of quick win to be had with any
data you have because naturally people
have videos lined about in fact
uh dale also did a really cool project
where she analyzed like
archival footage that our data recorded
so it goes to show like people just have
like videos and like unstructured data
which is what we call like videos and
like
text and stuff they just have that lying
around so just using one of these apis
with the data you already have
is a really cool way to kind of just
like almost get motivated when you're
getting into machine learning so yeah
that's my
recommendation is get a quick win using
an api
yeah it makes a lot of sense and zach
some of those stories that
you know that we've built as a team like
are just really good ways to get
you mentioned um uh looking at some some
of the family photos and categorizing
them another thing
that you know folks have been really
excited about is we did a series around
uh
taking a pdf file and turning it into an
audio book and
kind of by trying to solve that problem
getting familiar with using some of our
speech apis and things like that so um
yeah i think it's all about
just like anything in tech just kind of
finding something that you're interested
in where maybe ai can apply and just go
ahead and go for it
uh if you're new to vertex uh there is
this there are several sessions of
course during i o
uh sarah robinson is giving one that's
an intro
that i think will do a nice just
overview of
getting to know the different services
how it works um
if you go to the documentation there are
several
kind of like hello world style tutorials
for
vision or uh nlp or
all the different types of ai that
you're going to find there so that'll
get you started
yeah my favorite one that sarah did i
think she just did the workshop
that must have just ended but it's
recorded um it's using tabula
tabular data in vertex to make a
prediction so that's um
another good io resource you should look
out for yeah
for sure uh okay so uh our next question
let's talk about
ml ops okay so um the the question is
uh it seems that vertex ai has a lot of
ml ops capabilities
why is mlaps important to developers
and i can start with this one so
you know the development world that
we've had some practices for a long time
right continuous integration continuous
development
we have ways that we you know unit tests
that we can check that what we're doing
uh it is going to work that as we make
changes to our code it's not going to
break
now machine learning is making
mission-critical decisions about things
you know it's
classifying things predicting things we
need that same level of
rigor around the models that we build to
prevent them
you know a disaster from happening a bad
model going to production
so ml ops is all about it so vertex ai
has some really interesting capabilities
built in so what is called manage
pipelines
and manage pipelines allows you to
create a reproducible pipeline a set of
steps
where you can basically hit the play
button and it will
uh if you you know if you code it this
way extract data from your data sources
build a model
deploy your model uh maybe validate the
data
that you're using to make sure that
maybe some of the data that you're
pulling from there weren't changes into
the schema or anything
and then maybe you evaluate your model
and make sure that the accuracy hasn't
gone down before you deploy it
those are all the kind of things that
you can do in a pipeline
another really cool thing is called
model monitoring
so um and i know zach wrote an article
about this a while back
about zombie uh data in your models it
was
very cool good introduction that uh you
could find on medium
and it's this idea that like um you know
you build models based on
data in the past but we all know things
change right and so
that model that had really good accuracy
could start to drift over time
and that's where model monitoring comes
in it's not like
typical software development where it
just breaks
it's you know works or it doesn't ml
there's a little more nuance where it
could work but it just starts to degrade
over time and model monitoring light to
catch that
so these these are just a couple
examples of the integrated
uh ways that you can apply devops
principles to ml that are all part of
vertex ai
so um definitely recommend checking that
out
um okay so our next question uh
is about uh leveraging pre-trained
models
uh from google so uh with that one
uh why don't we start with zach oh yeah
so
this is my like it's my bread and butter
here so
uh i love just building things really
quickly so uh a great thing with
retrained apis
you don't need to do the like the most
intense part of the machine learning
process which is actually
building the model getting the data set
making sure it's like
clean and stuff and then training your
model and then the deployment of it you
don't do any of that you can just call
an api
and send your data to it and you get a
response from the api so yeah like i
said previously
favorite ones video intelligence and
there's ones for
image prediction and text prediction and
uh yeah they're just really fun almost
to play with especially like uh
if you're involved in any hackathons it
goes to show how quickly you can use
them
and they even have uh built-in demos for
the vision api
right into the docs page where you can
just well what i'll usually do if
someone's just like
building an image uh based like app for
machine learning is i'll say
go to the docs drag the image that
you're planning to use or an example
image
into the the demo there and see what it
returns and just see like is any of this
useful and if it is
then you probably just use the api and
it's it tells you right there the
web request the send to call the api so
it's very much like try it
it's free to try and instant so you'll
find out immediately if it can be useful
and if it is
uh it's quick as well to just implement
so it's one of these things like i said
previously it's just a really quick win
if it can solve your problems so it's
like worth trying out so i'd say
look look into the docs there's usually
like quick to activate demos
and yeah just try them out yeah i love
those demos that we have it and all the
landing pages so not only
you know video intelligence and vision
but also nlp
maybe you're working with some text data
and you want to gather sentiment
you can put some samples in there and
get that back um
you know as far as on the pre-trained
side uh you know we've had some of the
basic
uh apis around for a while and um let's
say that you're in industry like
healthcare
or financial services um you know we're
building on top of these
to have even more specialized apis that
you can use so
you might be familiar with natural
language um well there's actually now a
healthcare natural language api that you
can also test out in the same way
so i'm just really excited to see you
know all these
things uh growing and being even more
targeted and useful to our developers
yeah there's a tool that solves your
problem quickly
go for it you know these apis uh allow
you to just integrate you know call the
rest api use the sdk
uh you don't have to train a model and
all that uh very quick so a
great place to get started one other
thing just to mention as far as
pre-trained models is
uh some of the models that you may have
heard of coming out of google research
are available on tensorflow hubs so you
can leverage
models that you may have heard of bert
for natural language processing and some
of the other image models
you can use those and even do things
like fine-tune those models where
um you know they're large models that
are trained on a general data set
but you can leverage their the concepts
that they've learned and kind of just
adjust them for your data set so
tensorflow hub is a great way to kind of
pull those down and
leverage those models if you want to do
some custom work
so um so let's move our next question uh
and i think that's a good follow up to
what we're talking about the zac and the
video api so what's your favorite ml api
that's underutilized by devs
well i know what my favorite is uh video
intelligence
uh it's what i think uh i think it's
probably not underutilized because i
think people
there's quite a lot of developers i've
already seen who are using it for doing
things like uh
label detection where it just gives you
like searchable terms for your video
and object detection those are two like
one of the most the most like mature
features of the api
but what people might not be aware of is
that there's actually loads and loads of
new features things around like
detecting people
and their poses that's not part of the
api uh things like
ocr is built in and brand detection
so maybe you're building an app you want
to detect if someone's doing like
product placement in it that's just
built into the api you don't need to
train your own model to do it
again it's one of these things like with
all the other uh apis
uh they have like a range of features
and they're constantly adding new
features to them so it's just worth like
if you're
working with video look at look at the
video intelligence api because it'll
probably be some useful features
and the same goes for like image and
natural language but yeah i think
certain features of the video
intelligence api are definitely like
right hot off the press so naturally
there's not going to be a lot of
developers aware of them but yeah
there's
some really cool features around like uh
person detection so yeah
video intelligence person detection oh
you know what i we haven't talked about
chat bots yet and that's also
a big part of our platform um also not
sure if it's unutilized but
let's talk about it now um dialog flow
uh
and contact center i think is um really
helpful if you are building a chatbot or
doing anything
uh conversationally um my background i
actually
worked in the chatbot space before i
came to ai and it is
really hard to build you know a useful
natural sounding chatbot
and so i highly recommend if you're that
is something you're looking into
go ahead and test out dialogflow because
um you can use natural language
capabilities out of the box
um but you can also uh you know augment
it with maybe like
your own data so it knows like special
nouns to your use case
so there's a lot in there and i think
it's a really neat product to
integrate with absolutely yeah and it's
really cool how a lot of the ai products
sort of work well with each other's
connections like you know the new you've
worked with uh you know chat bots
with that where there's natural language
there's speech elements to them
document uh ai you know has sort of that
uh ocr and also you know text processing
so
um anyway just lots lots of different
ways to go about it
um so our next question uh i think is a
really good one from the audience um
especially if you're a developer and
you're not
really sure should i apply ai to this or
not so the
question is how do you spot a problem
which can be
aified i like that versus more
conventional methods
and i can start off with this one um
that i think that um
you know the real difference between ai
and and traditional software development
is
uh that in software development you know
you have a set of inputs
and you know what the rules are right
you're coding it up
if this then that and then you come up
with an output
ai is good when you don't really know
what those rules should be right you
have a set of inputs
and you have a set of outputs like i
have a bunch of pictures
and i know i can label what's in those
pictures
but i'm not exactly sure how i got from
point a to point b what were the rules
what with us the particular pixels and
colors that led to that
or another example might be um like
you're doing some forecasting on the
future you know you're
looking at uh you know the markets and
you're trying to look at these trends
over time
you don't know what those rules are but
that's where uh machine learning can
come in maybe that there's some pattern
that can be discovered so essentially
what you're doing is you're figuring out
uh what those rules are versus
traditional methods
you kind of have an approach you know
what those
rules or heuristics are so uh surf does
a little philosophical of an answer but
that's kind of my
take on that uh zachary knew any other
thoughts on
when to spot a good ai problem
i have um i have like a kind of funny i
guess
rule of thumb you know if you can do it
with a sql query
and you don't actually have unknowns it
might not be the right problem but
there could be other problems in your
space that you need to think about that
don't actually have common paths that ai
could help you
but you know definitely be careful
because um
you know there is a little bit of a
known in the mix uh check out
explainable ai
because you know if you're doing
something that you know you have users
you want to be really careful and
transparent about
um what you're doing with data so that's
my
rule of thumb i guess that's i think
i've got a similar thing where
it's like rather than knowing like what
can be ai
knowing like for sure what doesn't need
to be ai it's kind of
as useful of a thing like i think
there's a there's a classic story of
like
how google detects when you should have
attached an attachment in a gmail thing
people like oh surely it's like you use
ai for that to do like
natural language classification like did
they say they would attach
an attachment and if it comes back like
predicting
they should have then send them that a
message but actually then
they worked as actually just an if
statement if they mention the word
attachment attached
people just use that it's like if you
can solve it with an if statement
probably don't need to use ai but then
uh also a thing
that i think is like what makes things a
bit simpler is that there's just so many
common patterns
like if you're working with images
that's classic video classic
large bodies of text classic ai all this
kind of
unstructured data that doesn't
necessarily fit into columns in a
database
then you can imagine there's something
to do with ai there and what i usually
recommend people who like ask me like oh
how would i solve this specific problem
with ai
i just asked oh well what problem that
you know is already solved with ai that
is similar to this
so someone was like oh how do i do this
thing with like uh
some obscure time series data is like
how do i solve this problem with ai i'd
be like well it kind of sounds like uh
it's called like trigger word detection
which is the same thing
they use when uh you're trying to
activate your phone's assistant
we're just detecting that one word over
time i was like look into that
that'll probably tell you the right
steps to take so yeah i'd recommend
just just exposing yourself and a good
thing is coming to this
uh ama is like just exposing yourself to
as many different random
solutions and then you'll you'll draw
links to be like oh they solve something
similar with ai maybe i can solve it
with this one as well so yeah just just
get out there and see all the different
demos and examples
good answer um so the next one i i think
is a good question because it's it's
funny how we're getting
questions on the questions we've already
answered so um
uh we have basically a few similar
questions i'm just going to group into
one here
um there was a question about where to
get the
step-by-step tutorials mentioned by anew
as well as the
tabular data tutorial and zox tutorial
so
i want to mention one resource code labs
codelabs.developers.google.com
uh you know you can google that and and
find it uh we have already
several vertex ai code labs available uh
in a whole bunch of other uh awesome
resources to learn
you know cloud ai tensorflow things like
that um
and uh so
yeah so um i was just gonna check you
know anew or zach any other thoughts on
where to get tutorials getting started
resources
yeah um i'm also in addition to code
labs that have the step-by-step
instructions i'm also
really a huge fan of the quick starts
and the code snippets that we have
embedded in our documentation
um for each for several of the api
methods we'll actually sketch it out for
you
in several different languages so java
node python
um so you can kind of copy and paste
into maybe a code sample
uh you know for the framework or service
that you're already using
or you know maybe something that you're
more familiar with
and these are all actually um we really
believe in open source so all of our
code snippets are
on github in repo so you know if there's
something that you want to contribute
or you know file a bug on or you know
ask for help
uh that's how you can get help with
those things
i totally i totally uh like plus one on
that like the codes
the code snippets in the docs are really
good source
also uh if you look towards the uh
official google cloud blog
we usually post around like really nice
like vertical solutions
in that involve like the ai and ml uh
apis and tools
all in like usually like within an
actual like story of how it's actually
used to solve a real problem
so that's also a good example of uh
seeing how they use and they'll also be
code snippets and samples and
links to github repos in there
perfect all right so um our next
question
is around doing ai in the cloud i really
like this question
um because it kind of brings all
together so the question is
why would i do ai in the cloud over
somewhere else
who wants to take that question
oh i so i i i i like this question
because yeah i
uh i started off like learning
programming using things like arduinos
like very low level
uh hardware devices so i've always been
like i always like building things
locally on my
my own computer machine and then when i
started learning about
uh machine learning and doing it all on
my own machine the first thing that i
encountered was
uh my per laptop couldn't handle the
amount of
data and training i run out of hard
drive space so like the biggest reason
i'd say
is a scalability of just the data set
itself
and considering that like the more data
you have the better your model it's
classic example
uh having a place where you can safely
upload
like huge data sets to train models and
not have to worry about
your like local computer like making
your own room very very warm
it's like a huge benefit for me uh so
that's my my main thing is just like
having a safe place uh where i can put
huge data sets
and do all the training in the cloud so
that i can like use my local machine to
do things which is
needs to do like playing games for sure
i mean i feel like that's almost you
know why cloud in general right like i
just want to write code i'm a developer
i don't want to have to do
the ops the you know system admin sort
of work
um and that's you know the point of
cloud is to sort of offload that so you
can really focus on like
what you actually the problem that
you're actually trying to solve
absolutely yeah and my experience was
kind of similar to
zach's is when i first got into data
science one of the things i would do is
go to
kaggle and uh it's a data science
community i was doing competitions like
one of them was
titanic that maybe some of you have
tried and i just remember spending
hours waiting for my model to train and
then i'd make little change and have to
wait my little
desktop computer was just you know
buzzing you know for hours right and
these are the kind of things if it's
taking too long you can you know
crank it up and have a you know higher
level
chip you know with more uh you know gpus
or more you know more ram you can really
just solve these problems so much
quicker
and then when you're done using it
you're done using it and you can you
know turn off your notebook
uh but anyway just fast uh easy to use
uh
i love it couldn't go back that's cute
and on that the big one uh another
huge one for me is when i first started
working at google i started building
demos then i started building
big demos that involved multiple people
and so like the amount of collaboration
that you can achieve when things are all
in the cloud like just adding a person
let me just add you to that project
and now you have access to the notebook
and stuff that i could never
do using a local machine because having
done data science projects
with just local machines like using
github and people have different
environments set up and
it saves so much hassle just being like
here's the notebook it's got everything
installed it's already
running you don't need to install
anything on your laptop you can even
access it on your phone if you want
like that the environment itself having
those libraries installed i'd say is
like one of the biggest
reasons for me oh yeah um so i actually
i didn't start coding until i was in
college and you know
you know when i first started i didn't
know about all these tools so i remember
doing group projects we would actually
be emailing
the code files back and forth to each
other so
uh you know thankfully tooling
is out there and readily accessible okay
well the fantastic conversation i think
we're out of time
everyone um a great question from the
audience
uh a new zack awesome being with you
again
uh thanks so much everyone we'll wrap up
our session today have a great day